competitive smash is no stranger to
broken characters whether it's pikachu
in 64 or meta knight and brawl or
bayonetta in smash 4 we have seen our
fair share of unfair busted stupid
characters over the years
but ultimate is currently being
dominated by maybe the weirdest broken
character a smash game has ever seen and
the entire scene is in an uproar asking
the same question
is minecraft steve ruining smash
[Music]
alright folks before we get into the
video i want to ask you to please sub to
the channel and turn on notifications if
you haven't done it yet it really does
help and once you've done that please
head over to twitch.tv sports and throw
us a follow there we are streaming all
the time and you don't want to miss a
stream okay so this past weekend there
were two really big smash ultimate
tournaments unsurprisingly mk leo won
the tournament he attended cossell in
france but everybody on twitter was
talking about what happened at get on my
level in toronto yeah big d you've got
to look out for a lot this game
definitely could be over looking for the
tru wait oh okay oh that might be gg's
oh my god how how did that work
though goodbye good night and that's a
theme w in gobble 2022 that was onan a
16 year old minecraft steve player who's
been on a bit of a hot streak over the
last few months he won gomel cost and
combo breaker the most unique thing
about onan is that he is a minecraft
steve may if you don't know steve he's
the
uh protagonist of minecraft i guess
no
oh
my
oh they put god
steve in his game
anyway they put him into smash in
october 2020 and we did a whole video
about it steve was a super weird but
also kind of exciting addition to smash
though he didn't see much of a
tournament presence until recently see
usually a 16 year old prodigy showing up
and winning a tournament with a
relatively unplayed character would get
people excited but that's not what's
happening instead twitter and reddit lit
up with people making calls to ban steve
and this isn't the first time it's
happened between onan's recent victories
the rise of 15 year old japanese steve
prodigy akola and other rising stars
like yoni and jake steve has been
popping up a lot in top base recently
and somehow that's already enough to
have people seriously discussing banning
him in fact some regions have already
banned the character and a decent part
of the smash community is worried that
steve is going to ruin ultimate in a
couple of years before i talk about
whether or not that's actually going to
happen let's talk about what makes steve
so hated first first is the fact that he
is just a really strong character
steve's whole gimmick is that he's
basically playing minecraft during a
match his specials let him mine for
resources and then use those resources
on his attacks or to build blocks or
even to craft new weapons to make him
stronger during a fight this is pretty
cool but also uniquely frustrating at a
competitive level steve players will
regularly just throw up some blocks to
create cover while they mine for
resources that forces the other player
to stand there and do nothing jump over
them and put themselves at risk or just
slowly break the box blocks also make
for a decent edge guarding tool and a
way to uh express your creativity there
is enough of a delay between that and
the earthquake hitbox which can shield
poke you after the first hit so oh is he
alive no no no oh what do you do
let's just say it was probably like big
d's little brother yeah all right all
right
steve also has his incredible minecart
side special which is a movement option
that propels steve forward a projectile
once he leaps out of it and on hit it's
a command grab that flings the opponent
halfway across the stage his down air
anvil is an incredible out of shield
punish and a good neutral tool his tnt
block is an all-in-one edge guarding
move his up air strings are ridiculous
his diamond tools let him kill at
absurdly low percent his up smash mega
block is gigantic and one of the best
anti-air options in the game and his
combos are well just look at this what
do you not need an iron sword for
down throw jab jab jab jab jab jab jab
jab
basically steve has a very fully
featured kit those are just a small
handful of some of his moves and they
already represent a massive amount of
capabilities imagine what he can do with
his full kit steve is a super flexible
character and any two players could
approach him completely differently
which is a part of why it took so long
for steve to pop off he got put into
ultimate almost two years ago and
because all the tournaments were online
he was so complicated to play we just
didn't see big tournament wins from
steve until very recently i think most
people agree that akola japan's current
best player put steve on the map he
destroyed japan's online tournaments
during covid then won their offline
tournaments and then finally came over
to the us recently to win the
invitational over some of north
america's best talents all right look at
this even the platform too nicole has
the platform above him the wall oh wait
we got some
up bro there it tricks there it is akola
is your gimmitational maybe first annual
imitational champion but now a wave of
young steve players are showing up and
flipping the script on a character that
some people thought was gimmicky and
weird
okay
riddles a whole stock down losing that
stock and record time that first one off
of a miss input
and now onan definitely been taking this
uh you know taking this one to the bank
oh my god even through the spot dodge
the backhand of the minecart and it's
over which in turn has led to lots and
lots of people trying to get him banned
over the last few months and a few
tournaments have actually already banned
steve a small french tournament called
croco cup and a small regional within
louisiana have both banned steve both in
a bid to get a discussion going about
the character now plenty of cooler heads
have stepped in to say that it's
probably too soon to actually ban steve
from all tournaments like i said earlier
smash has seen its fair share of broken
characters and while baynetta and
metanite the most broken characters in
their respective games were banned by a
few smaller tournaments they never
received community-wide blanket bans and
steve is not dominating ultimate to the
level that those two dominated their
games and yet the banning conversation
keeps coming up because the problem
isn't just that steve is super strong
it's that he kind of fundamentally runs
counter to the way that smash fans want
their game to work i had a couple of
really interesting conversations on
twitter yesterday with smash fans about
why people hate steve shout outs to lsw
and 2dad's kissing for sharing their
thoughts by the way what i got for these
conversations is that steve runs
contrary to the game in two major ways
one he is the most mechanically unique
character in the entire game and even if
his tools weren't super strong losing to
him feels bad because he's just really
hard to prepare for it's like a really
lame knowledge check on top of that
steve's tools fundamentally slow the
game down smash fans tend to like it
when their games are fast with lots of
decision points but steve's blocks
basically act as a one-sided zoning tool
they force the other player to either
carefully break them or put themselves
at risk of getting up aired by his
gigantic up smash or yielded across the
stage by his minecart the other big
reason people hate steve is that a lot
of smashers just don't think he fits in
the game i mean just think back to the
reactions to his announcement video i
don't believe it
i don't believe it i'm gonna turn the
stream off right now i'm gonna turn this
[ __ ] off steve isn't an iconic nintendo
character he isn't a representative of
some classic hardcore gaming franchise
he is a weird blocky looking dude from a
game that most smash fans probably write
off as kitty [ __ ] he doesn't fit in with
the rest of the cast both from an
aesthetic and pedigree perspective i
think that putting steven smash was
actually really cool but i think that if
you don't feel that way losing to him
probably feels even worse and i imagine
most of the people calling for a steve
man didn't even want him in the game in
the first place personally i think it's
way too early to ban steve the results
just aren't there yet and honestly i
think he's probably a more interesting
and difficult character to play than
meta knight or bayonetta were not to
mention the fact that these steve
players have yet to go up against
players like mk leo tweek and meister
they've played against incredible
players to be sure but they've yet to go
up against the absolute top echelon of
ultimate talent and i think we should
reserve judgment until they do steve is
now enemy number one in the ultimate
community it's possible that players
come together and make counterplay for
him and knock him out of the meta it's
also possible that he is legitimately
broken there is no counter play and we
keep circling around this band
discussion either way i think we can all
agree that nobody thought the character
that would tear the smash community
apart would be the guy from
minecraft
i just legitimately i just every time i
come back to it it's like really it's
steve this is the guy the minecraft guy
yeah that's exactly that's exactly like
oh pikachu can generate a million volts
of electricity meta knight is like an
interdimensional immortal space warrior
bayonetta is literally like satan or
something minecraft steve is a guy